I want to tell you about the first time
I was 21 years old and I saw six million
dollars of cash right in front of me I
couldn't believe it I'm like you got to
be kidding me that's what 6 million
looks like insane how the hell can I get
this kind of money one day and the guy
who had the six million dollars was a
Jewish businessman who owned dealerships
in San Fernando Valley area and he gave
me an advice at 21 that completely
changed the way I do business till today
by the way if you get value from today's
message give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel here's what
this Jewish businessman told me I said
how is it possible you got this much
money and you're in your mid 30s six
million cash he says Patrick there's one
thing you need to know about Jews I said
what's that when one makes money five
make money I said what he says when one
of us makes money in a business five
other Jews make money because we like to
make money in groups I said so what's
the benefit of that he said everybody
keeps doing business together he says
too many people ethnicities
nationalities cultures backgrounds they
just want to be the one making money
they don't want anybody else around them
making money and eventually they wonder
how come nobody wants to go into
business with me because when you make
money nobody else makes money so ask
yourself the question number one the
person you're working for does he make
money and do you make money and number
two the people that work with you who
report to you if they give their best do
they also make good money the way you're
making money if the answer is yes you're
in a great place go do your part and
eventually you'll make your money like
that Jewish Mentor shared with this 21
year old 24 years ago 23 years ago if
you got value from this video give it a
thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
and if you've never watched a video 20
rules of money how actually money Works
click here to watch the video 20 rules
of money take care everybody
foreign